government comes in and adds these
quotas they discriminate against men for
jobs they overpay women for doing the
same work as guys and actually pay women
more per hour and you'll see this trend
of smart educated women dying alone and
really um the women that I think of that
over like I don't want to say overcame
this but
um like the women that I see that are
smart and educated have to they have to
date quote unquote down an example that
chick from precious the Gabrielle
Gabrielle tick
um she dated down girl from Bumble
Whitney wolf heard she dated down Oprah
dated down and I'm not saying dated down
in all aspects you know I'm sure they
outdid her in them and some but it's
just if you're gonna make a lot of money
as a chick you have to understand what
comes with it what is supposed to come
with it it's either you date down you
quit your job then you date up or you
die alone